hi this is a huge day not just for Star
Wars fans but actually for the British
film industry we fought very hard as a
government to get Star Wars made in
Britain because we knew it would bring
jobs and investment it would mean that
we had great opportunities for British
actors so it's a great day for
filmmaking in this country and it
clearly shows the forces with us so the
galaxy far far away is part of the long
long term economic blog ya know like I
mean it's I for my generation you know
we grew up with the Star Wars movies and
to have a whole new set of Star Wars
maybe movies made here in Britain with
British actors in British Studios
creating British jobs is a really big
thing for this country it's a boost for
our economy it's a boost for our culture
and our film industry niche shows as I
say the force is with us and are you
looking forward to seeing the film
you're a star Wars fan yourself you've
got a favorite character well I'm in
like everyone I'm a bit of a hand solo
fan and it's good to see he's going to
be back because I've seen him on the
posters and the trailer but I can't wait
to see the movie myself